Nevada home of casinos impulse weddings
legal brothels and as of July first
recreational marijuana the truth is the
state has never been anything close to a
free-market paradise everything from the
Las Vegas taxi industry to prostitution
is controlled by a handful of
politically connected companies license
to operate by the government
this means exorbitant prices and
unnecessary hassles for customers and
businesses the latest industry to take
hold here legal weed is no exception
Governor Brian Sandoval recently
declared a state of emergency because
Nevada's 37 licensed marijuana shops are
running out of inventory how could that
be the law legalizing weed in Nevada
also granted an 18-month monopoly on
distribution to liquor companies not
only to alcohol wholesalers lack the
experience or infrastructure to
transport marijuana most are too afraid
to even enter the market because they're
regulated by the federal government and
marijuana is still considered illegal on
the federal level
and there isn't a shortage of cannabis
as much as there is a shortage of
distributors Hartmann Yemeni Jian the
owner of essence a marijuana dispensary
just north of the Vegas Strip started
out running a facility for medical
marijuana which was legalized in Nevada
back in 2015 when he was dealing with
medical cannabis his employees simply
moved inventory from the grow house to
the storefront themselves now that
essence is selling recreational
marijuana that's no longer an option
our cultivation facility is no more than
a couple miles from our dispensary even
worse there are some cultivations that
are in the same building as the
dispensaries the medical market faced
other regulatory hurdles which is one
reason the line on the medical side of
the store has nobody standing in it if
you're using the penetration rates from
other states we should have had fifty to
sixty thousand medical patients the
process of obtaining a card and that you
were in the state's database and that
you couldn't have a CCW and then the
fact that sometimes it took patients up
to six months to get a card really
discouraged a lot of patients from
getting their medical cards
Yamini Jen says he's managed to work out
a temporary deal with a liquor
distributor to keep his shelf stocked
for the time being but other stores are
running dangerously low on inventory the
state is trying to devise a workaround
that would allow some marijuana sellers
to move their own product again
recreational marijuana has the potential
to provide visitors to Sin City and
especially fun and safe way to enjoy
themselves and it could be a huge boon
to the state economy but it won't live
up to its full potential until
politicians stop using every vice as a
means to reward special interests you
have to treat it like any other business
it doesn't make sense
to over-regulate because at that point
all that cost is is passed on to the
consumer if the prices were a little
lower probably take away from the black
market as opposed to giving people a
reason to go to the black market
[Music]
you